nous devons aller vers la vaccination de
tous les français
car c'est le seul chemin vers le retour
à la vie normale dans un premier temps
pour les personnels soignants et non
soignants des hôpitaux des cliniques des
maisons de retraite des établissements
pour personnes en situation de handicap
pour tous les professionnels aux
bénévoles qui travaillent au contact des
personnes âgées ou fragiles y compris à
domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre pour tous nos compatriotes
concernés ils auront jusqu'au 15
septembre pour se faire vacciner dès le
21 juillet le pass sanitaire sera
étendue aux lieux de loisirs et de
culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
pressant à partir du début du mois
d'août donc le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux mais aussi dans les avions
trains et cars pour les longs trajets
cet automne les fameux tests pcr seront
rendus payants
sauf prescription médicale et ceci afin
d'encourager la vaccination plutôt que
la multiplication des tests parce que le
niveau de vaccination y est encore très
insuffisant et que les hôpitaux sont
déjà sous forte pression forte pression
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sera déclaré
dès demain en conseil des ministres pour
la martinique et la réunion et un
couvre-feu sera instauré qui que nous
devrons engager dès que les conditions
sanitaires seront réunies la réforme des
retraites
oui parce que nous vivons longtemps il
nous faudra travailler plus longtemps et
partir à la retraite plus tard